the US Department of Justice has
launched an inquiry into Ober the
ride-hailing giant is being investigated
for the use of its great ball software
to identify and evade government
officials those officials were trying to
shut down Ober in areas where the
service had not been approved
uber says the software was created to
protect drivers but the company is it to
avoid investigators uber said no comment
when CBS News asked about the Department
of Justice inquiry CBS News contributed
that stick list Thompson is editor in
chief of Wired magazine
mr. dapper joins us once again at the
table run again it's always good to see
you it seems like when it rains it pours
for uber yes really describe what gray
ball is and why this investigation is
important so Grabel has technology that
uber uses to make its cars either appear
invisible or unreachable to government
officials or other people so the big
problem happened in the city of Portland
where uber was operating without
approval from the city
so what Oberer did is he created a
geofence around government offices and
figured out through credit cards and
social media information who were
government officials and then made it so
if those people were trying to hail an
uber they wouldn't be able to get it or
they would see different uber cars now
uber claims that this technology was
created to protect drivers and serve
users but it does certainly seem to have
been used to avoid government
investigate one is the investigation and
coming on top of all these other
headlines and investigation what does it
mean for uber
it means uber is in a lot of trouble and
probably regrets its philosophy which
it's had since the beginning which is to
move very fast and deal with the law
later and it's coming up - it's catching
up with ruber right now but who were
admitted that they used it is that
significant well they don't really have
a choice I mean there's there's very
clear evidence that they used it they've
admitted these it they claim that they
use it for Oh after a sports team wins
you can use this technology to have the
cars look a little different with the
logo of the team but it does seem very
clear that it was used mostly to help
them move into cities where government
officials were resistance clearly uber
had a strategy to grow as fast as you
can increase market share as fast as you
can does that now look like a policy and
a strategy and a company philosophy that
was not wise well uber is also worth 65
billion dollar
so maybe it was wise right because one
of the advantages you move fast you
break the law you get going really
quickly and then you get the data which
allows you to get a monopoly position
you get all the drivers you get all the
users people use your app their network
effects so the people who move fast and
are able to get stuff on the road
quickly are able to build a monopoly
position there is one big problem though
if uber which is now in lawsuit in
litigation with Google loses that that
is a serious problem so Google has
abundance of all problem the Google
lawsuit is huge is a Google lawsuit
which is ongoing right now is by far the
biggest thing they're facing so there is
a senior executive on Google
self-driving car program who left Google
started a new company and then went over
Google alleges that he stole technology
if that goes wrong for uber that is big
and bad right to be continued for sure
Thank You Nick Tom Thank You Gail